we're back with
stains of course rahan
who's zoom got disconnected
oh my gosh michael you drink your coffee
and your green juice
i'm thinking you drink it like robert
hayes an airplane when he's like
um so this is the green juice right here
all right you can see it sort of looks
like dribble all right
and then we have the remnants
of a coffee stain you don't want this
on your jacket you came to the right
place all right
i'm gonna go warm
[Music]
putting your hands in warm water is just
the oddest sensation
all right so i'm gonna get the warm
water and i'm gonna just
start getting just a little bit of
wetness in there yep there we go
i just want a little water and what i
want that water for
is i just want the moisture
because i'm going to go with a little of
an old classic
my dr bronner's baby mild they have
every kind of
like scent in the world but i'm going to
go
with a clear soap here because what i
want
is an undyed viscosity i do not want
foam right now i want the soap to go
into the fiber then
ladies you might recognize this it's a
buff puff
but what i have here again is there's no
dye in this
so i do not want the dye to go into the
jacket
all right
i have to say if one day i could be the
master of
anything well first it would be
you know raising my daughters properly
um i'd like to be that kind of master
but
second in line second in line would be
stains
that's right the fabric actually
has and is treated with some type of
wicking
so i'm impressed you even got a stain on
this
in the first place because this is not a
porous fiber all right
this is literally like foolproof
so well done sir in
literally protecting those that you
dress
all right now i'm actually going to go
in the cold water because it doesn't
have any soap
and i'm just going to pat pat pat
because ironically
if i wipe it with the paper towel you're
going to get little cheese curds of
paper towel and we don't want that
no no no no we don't now see it already
started to happen
it's like paper cottage cheese that's
not soap
i used the wrong material i knew it
sometimes i just do it to myself
you know it's like
amateur hour over here i know not to rub
with a paper towel
you need a washcloth for this
all right now the stain is gone but the
wetness remains
cindy bring me
the dryer
yes a stinger
[Applause]
come on don't go into the light
clear
[Applause]
ah it's alive
it's alive
all right this is wet
but it's clean
and when i get a stinger that works i
will
prove it and i will stay here until
every fiber on this beautiful wicked
hard to penetrate fabric is dry
remember collection by michael strahan
is available
online and now in select men's warehouse
stores nationwide
and msx by michael strahan
for nfl is also available on msx by
michael strahan.com
gift guide by the way one for yourself
and one for others what a great gift for
the holidays
we're almost out of time but guess what
so is michael strahan he's back too
hi michael hey drew we lost you a little
earlier but it actually all worked out
perfectly and now you're in a location a
new location for a better connection
yes i am i'm actually at home for a much
better connection
what do you think i you know what
whoa you know i'm watching i'm watching
with jamie and you said your skills in
the kitchen
but you're skilled to get the same out
are unbelievable oh wow
well michael i really wanted to impress
you you are someone i truly admire
and just like i think you're so rad and
i
had to like get this right for you i was
really feeling a lot of pressure and
your collection
by michael strahan that's now available
at men's warehouses stores nationwide
oh and the collection by michael
strahan.com and
msx by michael strahan for nfl is
available on msx
by michael strahan.com and i love this
jacket
and it let me do my thing so thank you
and i love
you michael strand i love you
and um i i'm just so happy you love me
on your show and great job you know what
if you get a stain on it just call drew
look up this segment she's got to cover
everybody
[Music]